you know what teenage girls and you find  out real quick you know what teenage  girls don't care about  is your feelings  [Applause]  yo dude i'm sure your daughter has said  something to your face where you're like  i would punch a grown man in the mouth  for saying that [ __ ] to me  [Applause]  can i tell you something she said to me  look we're at the  we're at the beach right and i'm at the  beach wearing beach attire you know  shorts no shirt  she's on her phone and by the way they  deliver their insults with zero emotion  right to your face super matter of fact  you know  so i'm at the beach she's got her phone  in her hand and she just walks by me and  she goes like this  nice titties  [Applause]  and i said these are packs  and she goes maybe they used to be but  those are titties now  [Applause]  right to my [ __ ] face  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]